merci Alexandra burger Fontain d'être
avec nous ce matin vous êtes sénatrice
des Alpes-Maritimes et porte-parole des
républicains on a beaucoup de sujets
aborder avec vous d'abord on l'a vu hier
cet hommage du Parlement aux policiers
tués à cette infirmière tuée les
policiers qui ont été tués par un
chauffard qui a été contrôlé positif au
stupéfiant qui est également alcoolisé
hier on a appris qu'une fille aide de 6
ans était tuée par une conductrice dans
les Yvelines là aussi tester positive au
stupéfiant vous aviez défendu une
proposition de loi avec le sénateur
Laurent saumon pour un meilleur
prévention des violences routières
est-ce qu'il faut enfin créer un délit
d'homicide routier selon vous alors je
crois que c'est un sujet aujourd'hui qui
fait plus que jamais l'actualité
d'ailleurs tristement médiatisé par
l'affaire Palmade il faut pas se cacher
c'est un débat sur lequel nous on
travaillait notamment avec mon collègue
de la Somme Laurence saumon parce que
nous avions été chacun sensibilité dans
notre territoire moi au sein des
Alpes-Maritimes à Antibes ou un jeune de
17 ans qui s'appelait Noé a été percuté
par un chauffard qui conduisait sous
l'emprise d'alcool et de stupéfiants et
qui 70 jours après la détention
provisoire a été libérée ce qui est très
dur pour les familles c'est vraiment une
sorte de double peine alors nous avons
travaillé bien sûr à une proposition de
loi qui est juste qui n'est pas
prétentieuse ou qui n'est pas
communicationnel mais qui demande
justement qui pose un certain nombre de
marqueurs essentiels d'abord de pouvoir
travailler à l'effectivité des peines le
cas que vous venez de dénoncer à
l'instant des policiers avec deux
circonstances agrémentes sachez que
c'est quand même puni de 10 ans de
prison 50000 euros d'amende sauf que
dans les faits ce sont des peines qui ne
sont pas appliquées donc nous on demande
justement l'applicabilité des peines je
crois que c'est ça le sujet majeur et
que l'ensemble des associations qui
luttent contre les violences routières
également demandent plus de prévention
également je crois que c'est un sujet
assez important en tout cas c'est un
sujet sur lequel il faut qu'on se penche
je crois qu'à chaque fois qu'on peut
apprendre des des incidents aussi
dramatiques que celui-là et de cette
fillette de 6 ans c'est ignoble je crois
qu'il faut vraiment adapter une réponse
pénale et vraiment pas besoin de changer
la loyal il y a même pas besoin de créer
un délit d'homicide routier il suffit
juste d'appliquer c'est une demande un
des familles des associations de le
qualifier on va dire c'est une question
sémantique d'homicide routier non plus
d'homicide involontaire je peux
comprendre que ça peut essayer en tout
cas de de guérir un peu les mots de
l'appeler un homicide routier dans les
faits il n'y a pas vraiment de
changement de qualification je crois que
je vous l'ai dit les peines encourus
sont déjà suffisamment importantes même
si rien ne remplace bien évidemment un
acte aussi terrible que même de faire
disons de prison en tout cas je pense
qu'il faut vraiment travailler à
l'effectivité des peines et à la plaque
l'appliquabilité c'est vraiment l'objet
de notre proposition de loi on a vu hier
l'hommage du Parlement à cette
infirmière qui a été tué au CHU de Reims
on va parler de cette actualité de ses
soignants de ces agressions de soignants
on va aller chez vous à Nice on retrouve
Denis carro bonjour Denis merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes directeur des
rédactions de Nice-Matin c'est la une et
le dossier de Nice-Matin aujourd'hui les
agressions personnelles soignants
oui effectivement nous revenons sur la
terrible agression et le décès de cette
infirmière au CHU de Reims un drame qui
scandalise la France et qui suscite
beaucoup d'émotions et de colère partout
et c'est le cas dans les dans les
Alpes-Maritimes évidemment où on observe
un comme ailleurs en France une
augmentation des violences envers les
soignants sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est plus 23% l'année dernière alors au
lendemain de du décès de de cette
infirmière ni ce matin consacre son fait
du jour à ce fleo et ses soignants
meurtri c'est ainsi que que nous titrons
le dossier à la à la Une nous avons
notamment recueilli le témoignage de
Jordan Jordan est un infirmier d'une
quarantaine d'années et il nous raconte
les multiples agressions qu'il a subi
ces dernières années dans l'exercice de
son métier à deux reprises notamment
Jordan a reçu des coups de poing alors
qu'il travaillait aux urgences et ne
compte plus les coups de pieds les
gifles les insultes il évoque aussi les
patients menaçants les familles
agressives la violence verbale au
quotidien envers envers les blouses
blanches un climat qui finit par miner
le moral des soignants et qui a pour
conséquence d'éloigner de plus en plus
de professionnels de santé de ce métier
si indispensable qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
pourtant choisi alors j'en viens à ma
question
à Alexandra borchio Fontain madame la
sénatrice est-ce qu'il faut comme
certains le demandent renforcer les
sanctions envers ceux qui s'en prennent
particulièrement au personnel soignants
d'abord je voudrais
redire toute mon émotion et mon soutien
d'abord aux proches de cette infirmière
de 37 ans qui est décédé sous les coups
de l'auteur d'une agression qui avait
déjà commis il faut le rappeler quand
même il y a quelques années des
violences
ignobles envers d'autres personnels
hospitaliers je crois qu'il y a deux
mesures et je m'associerai d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui à la mine de silence qui est
demandé dans la plupart des centres
hospitaliers de France en soutien à cet
acte ignoble je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
faut non seulement renforcer et
instaurer à mon sens une peine plancher
contre tous ceux qui qui s'en prennent
au personnel soignants vous parliez à
l'instant du chiffre de 23% des médecins
qui sont agressés sachez qu'en 2022 il y
a une augmentation de 37% des
professionnels de santé qui a été
augmenté c'est une augmentation des
faits de violence qu'on retrouve dans
notre dans d'autres services mais qu'on
ne peut pas qu'il nous faut absolument
adapter une réponse pénale donc je
soutiens d'ailleurs une proposition loi
d'un collègue de l'Assemblée nationale
Yannick de der qui est m’instaurait une
pleine plancher pour les auteurs de
violence envers les professionnels de
santé puis je crois que plus globalement
puisque là il s'agit d'un auteur des
faits qui visiblement en tout cas aurait
donc une maladie mentale c'est
indéniable je crois qu'il faut aussi
travailler un grand plan sur la
psychiatrie je crois qu'en depuis 1980
les le nombre de lits en psychiatrie a
considérablement baissé alors qu'il y a
de plus en plus de demandes de prise en
charge de passion à temps de maladies
mentale donc là aussi je pense qu'il
faut un plan assez conséquent c'est une
volonté aussi de notre famille politique
voilà de d'investir dans un plan de
psychiatrie pour justement essayer de
répondre à cette problématique et
stopper cette violence envers les
soignants
Denis une autre question regarde votre
une au-delà de la
au delà de la situation de la psy et de
la psychiatrie est-ce que c'est pas la
situation de l'hôpital globalement qui
qui pose problème et qui fait qu'on se
retrouve face à ce type de situation
alors l'hôpital qui pose problème je
vais pas je veux pas porter évidemment
une accusation contre le personnel
hospitalier je suis vice-présidente de
la Fédération hospitalière de France
dans ma région provençale-côte d'Azur et
je soutiens coûte que coûte des un
prophète de santé qui qui travaille et
qui donne un maximum de leur temps de
leur énergie de leur engagement pour
essayer de faire fonctionner un système
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il peut
paraître à bout de souffle qui manque
clairement de soutien malgré les les
différents plans annoncés par le
gouvernement Macron je crois aujourd'hui
en tout cas qu'il y a une vraie prise en
compte qui doit se faire du personnel
hospitalier et puis je veux rappeler
aussi que cette violence envers les
soignants sont partout en France de
nicaro est actuellement en direct de
Nice le 9 mai devant l'hôpital Pasteur
de Nice il y a eu un médecin du Samu qui
a été violemment agressé je crois que ce
sont vraiment des actes qu'on ne peut
pas tolérer envers ce justement qui se
sont engagés pour nous soigner
merci beaucoup Denis merci d'avoir été
avec nous depuis Nice la Une de Nice
Matin et le dossier de Nice-Matin on
regarde la une soignant meurtrie c'est à
la Une de votre journal aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup Denis carreau un mot sur
les agressions d'élus puisque
aujourd'hui aura lieu à Saint-Brévin la
marche en soutien aux merdes
missionnaire qui a démissionné on le
rappelle parce que son domicile a été
partiellement calciné il avait alerté
sur l'abandon de l'État hier on l'a
entendu dans le journal Eric
Dupond-Moretti devant le Sénat s'en est
défendu la justice locale n'a pas été
aux abonnés absents a-t-il dit est-ce
que l'État est suffisamment présent aux
côtés des élus pour vous bien sûr que
non et je crois que le témoignage de
sommaire de Saint-Brevin pour être un
témoignage d'autres élus d'autres mères
en France
Eric Dupond-Moretti dans son rôle de
tenter en tout cas de réparer une
carence là où l'État a été clairement
défaillant je crois que le président de
l'AMF David Lisnard est pleinement
engagé contre les violences contre les
élus il travaille ardemment aux côtés du
gouvernement pour justement proposer un
plan à la hauteur des ambitions
aujourd'hui il y a de plus en plus de
démissions de mer près de 1300
d'émissions depuis 2020 c'est énorme je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut un vrai
statut de l'élu il faut que là aussi
dans le même cas que les infirmières je
pense que n'importe quel personnalité en
tout cas a commencé par les élus et les
maires doivent pouvoir bénéficier d'une
protection différente d'un citoyen
lambda donc là aussi je suis soutiendrai
toute mesure en faveur de peine plancher
contre les auteurs de violences envers
les élus de la République je crois que
c'est important aujourd'hui de le
rapporter un soutien clair et de ne pas
réagir c'est à dire arriver après une
action la démission de Saint-Brevin il
est encore en vie mais sachez qu'il a
aussi démissionné de son de son métier
de médecin tellement il a été la commune
et tellement il a été affecté et ils
sont aujourd'hui un déménagement on a vu
que des agressions d'élus ont conduit à
la mort des élus donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut une véritable ça
devient
urgent je sais que la MF y travaille
j'espère que le gouvernement répondra à
hauteur des enjeux et de cette crise
terrible de la démocratie des élus qu'on
vit en ce moment en France
on va parler du texte dont vous êtes la
rapporteur qui a été voté hier soir par
le Sénat taxe issu de l'Assemblée
nationale pour instaurer une majorité
numérique et lutter contre la haine en
ligne on va voir les détails et la
séance avec ce jour-là
[Musique]
bonjour madame messenatrices et Steve le
Sénat donc adopté hier soir une
proposition de loi pour instaurer une
majorité numérique qui avait urgence à
agir parce qu'il est sur Oriane c'est
que les mineurs sont plus victimes
d'Internet que les autres catégories de
la population je vais vous donner
quelques chiffres premiers constat les
plus jeunes sont très présents et très
nombreux en ligne 82 % des 10 14 ans
consultent internet sans leurs parents
c'est des chiffres de la CNIL pour les
mineurs internet c'est aussi et
peut-être surtout en fait 28% c'est
aussi surtout les réseaux sociaux et
justement ces réseaux sociaux qui sont
très utilisés 28% des 7 10 ans se
rendent régulièrement sur un réseau
social c'est une enquête
ipso 60% des 11-18 seraient par exemple
inscrits sur Tik Tok alors cette
présence en ligne n'est pas
problématique en soi mais les experts
tirent la sonnette d'alarme elle
augmenterait les risques de dépendance
les risques de harcèlement encore les
risques de faire de mauvaises rencontres
c'est à dire de tomber sur des
prédateurs sexuels ou encore des dealers
et alors que prévoit oit le texte adopté
hier soir mais il fixe une borne à
partir de laquelle le mineur devra
obtenir l'accord des parents pour
s'inscrire sur un réseau social écouter
la secrétaire d'État à l'enfance
Charlotte cobel
s'inscrire sur un réseau social n'est
pas un acte anodin en particulier
lorsqu'on est encore enfant
sur un réseau social les enfants sont
confrontés sont confrontés eux-mêmes au
même risque que dans la vie réelle je
dirais même une fois parfois plus que
dans la rue la vie réelle les réseaux
sociaux sont source de danger réel et
graves en cela contrôler et accompagner
l'accès des mineurs à l'entrée des
réseaux est une réponse efficace la
proposition de loi a été adoptée début
mars à l'Assemblée nationale elle a été
amendée hier par les sénateurs très
concrètement avec les modifications
apportées par le Sénat en dessous de 15
ans le mineur pourra s'inscrire sur
n'importe quel réseau social s'il a
l'accord d'un des deux parents au dessus
de 15 ans il est un majeur dit numérique
il peut donc faire ce qu'il souhaite
question très simple madame la sénatrice
comment vous allez vérifier l'âge des
enfants qui se connectent en ligne et
qui s'inscrivent sur les réseaux sociaux
alors le procédé vise justement à ce que
l'arcome produise un référentiel c'est à
dire une liste justement d'éléments
technologiques dont les plateformes les
réseaux sociaux vont devoir on va avoir
l'obligation de s'emparer pour vérifier
au large là je pardon l'auteur cette
proposition de loi dont laquelle j'ai
été rapporteur visait justement à poser
le débat à échanger aussi au sein des
familles je pense que ça suscite un
certain nombre de questionnements mais
c'est surtout un constat vous avez
rappelé des chiffres essentiels c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on s'inscrit sur un
réseau social à 8 ans et demi la moitié
des 6-10 ans sont titulaires
propriétaires en tout cas d'un téléphone
portable donc 6 ans je rappelle c'est
quand on rentre au CP qu'on apprend à
lire donc aujourd'hui les parents
mettent très facilement des tablettes
dans les mains des enfants et je pense
forcément imaginer que le contenu qui
peut être diffusé peut-être
difficilement digérer par un enfant nous
en tant qu'adulte on a le discernement
nécessaire pour pouvoir digérer ce qu'on
voit ce n'est pas le cas des enfants
donc je crois que cette proposition de
loi en tout cas elle avait vocation à
poser le débat quant à l'applique
militait de un problème
peut le savoir on a voté hier soir le
texte donc on est moins de 12 heures
après toute façon est-ce qu'on pourra
encore mentir sur son âge quand on
s'inscrit sur un réseau social c'est
très facile il n'y a aucune technologie
au monde qui est infaillible mais à
partir de ce moment-là alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait soit on se dit de toute façon
pourra toujours la contourner ça sert à
rien c'est déjà un petit peu le cas en
ce moment les plateformes interdisent au
moins de 13 ans mais on sait bien qu'on
en changeant la date de naissance un peu
comme l'accès au site internet on clique
en disant qu'on a plus de 18 ans je
crois qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas comme
pour le rapport porno dans laquelle j'ai
été co-auteur il faut véritablement à
nous législateurs en tout cas poser un
seuil de maturité un âge légal c'est à
dire que à moins de 15 ans on peut
consulter on interdit pas de consulter
mais on place l'autorité parentale au
cœur du dispositif c'est-à-dire que
c'est le parent qui va décider si
l'enfant va pouvoir avoir un réseau
social mais ce qu'il faut savoir aussi
et ce que j'ai précisé hier dans ma
prise de parole c'est que d'autoriser un
enfant à accéder à un réseau social
c'est une chose mais contrôler ce qui
regarde c'est mieux alors évidemment
c'est impossible pour un parent de
rester collé à son enfant à regarder
exactement ce qu'il fait mais vous
parliez à l'instant d'un pourcentage de
d'enfants en fait qui consultent sont
les parents à plus de 80 %
alors c'est une suite logique les
parents reconnaissent à 80 % évidemment
qui ne savent pas exactement ce que font
leurs enfants sur Internet et c'est tout
là le problème des muni parce que aussi
les enfants ils maîtrisent mieux la
technologie que les parents numériques
aussi et je pense en fait que cette
proposition de loi au contraire va
servir aussi de d'instaurer le débat à
la maison et va servir de garde-fou et
aussi et d'aide aux parents justement en
un peu les responsabilisants et je
trouve que c'est une proposition de loi
qui est une proposition de bon sens qui
fait consensus on a travaillé avec le
gouvernement maintenant la main il y a
des amendements qui ont été adoptés de
la part de l'opposition sanatoriale
parce que c'est un sujet avec comme seul
objectif elle vient de la protection
le président du groupe horizon sur
lequel tout à fait le monde s'est mis
d'accord et donc c'est un sujet en en
tout cas transpartisans avec comme je le
disais le seul objectif et la protection
de l'enfant donc je crois que c'était
important aujourd'hui de poser un cadre
légal comme pour le cas des sites
internet
pornographiques qui sont accessibles
aujourd'hui à l'encontre de la loi au
mineur donc voilà c'est un texte a fait
consciencieux je rappelle quand même
qu'elle a été voté à l'unanimité hier
les sanctions sont prévues contre les
réseaux sociaux oui de 1% de leur
chiffre d'affaires mondial donc je pense
que c'était c'est des sanctions qui sont
importantes parce que mais ils ont cette
prise de conscience dans le cadre de ce
rapport bien sûr j'ai mené des auditions
avec la plupart des plateformes qu'on
connaît tous ils ont pleinement
conscience aujourd'hui que même si eux
ce n'est pas une loi mais ce sont
harmonisés entre eux pour interdire
l'accès enfin empêcher l'accès au moins
de 13 ans en considérant que leurs
réseaux social est accessible après 13
ans mais ils ont les données du nombre
de moins de 13 ans qui consultent qu'ils
n'ont pas souhaité me livrer évidemment
mais ils ont pleinement conscience que
le l'âge des utilisateurs est de plus en
plus jeunes et que même si bien sûr ils
mettent en place parce que c'était pas
un texte à charge contre les réseaux
sociaux heureusement ils ont aussi des
aspects positifs et tu essayes de mettre
en place des garde-fous des sanctions en
essayant de censurer et de supprimer ou
de signaler des contenus qui seraient
pas approprié seulement aujourd'hui il y
a aucune technologie qui permet à priori
à Forterie justement de limiter le
contenu donc je crois que cette
proposition de loi permet de poser ce
cadre d'alimenter le débat et de prendre
conscience surtout quand on est éclairé
par les littérature scientifiques et le
nombre de données qu'aujourd'hui il y a
de vrais dangers et que c'est important
aujourd'hui d'en parler vous l'avez un
peu modifié quand même ce texte
issu de l'Assemblée nationale notamment
sur la question de l'accord parental que
vous avez simplifié oui je sais souhaité
simplifier l'accord parental parce que
c'est une difficulté réelle
quand on réduit une proposition de loi
c'est c'est bien de la faire quand même
dans les en s'inspirant quand même de de
modèle en j'avais dire un peu personnel
je suis aussi maire de famille
d'adolescents je crois que c'est
important de recueillir la vie des deux
parents pour des décisions on dit
usuelles c'est à dire grave une
opération
un voyage à l'étranger ou tout autre
décision un peu plus importante je pense
que de demander à un des deux parents
l'autorisation à mon sens semblait
suffisant en accord d'ailleurs avec le
l'auteur de la proposition de loi
c'était une amendement aussi qui a été
largement compris donc il y a aussi sa
pause à partir du moment où on demande
aux deux parents des difficultés
techniques vous le savez il y a des des
pairs ou des mères surtout à 82% qui
sont isolés donc l'autorité parentale un
des deux parents donne l'autorisation on
a jugé en tout cas que c'était suffisant
vous l'avez dit vous êtes la co-auteur
du rapport du Sénat sur la pornographie
Jean-Noël Barrault il rappelait que 2
millions d'enfants sont exposés chaque
mois à des contenus pornographiques
est-ce que ce texte va aussi permettre
de lutter contre ça
alors
ce texte là de la proposition loi visait
exclusivement l'usage des réseaux
sociaux il y a un projet de loi
numérique qui sera émail examiné au
Sénat fin juin de mi-juillet porter
évidemment par le ministre Jean-Noël
Barrault qui vise justement à reprendre
nos préconisations qu'on avait fait avec
Laurence Cohen Annick Billon et Laurence
Rossignol suite au rapport un port de
l'enfer du décor qui a fait grand bruit
qui est sorti à peu près il y a un an
nous l'avons traduit dans une
proposition de résolution qui a été là
aussi adoptée à l'unanimité qui a été la
proposition de résolution la plus signée
enfin le texte législatif pardon le plus
signé de la Cinquième République déjà là
aussi c'est un sujet quand même
transparciant qui a mis tout le monde
d'accord parce qu'il s'agit de la
protection des mineurs et qu'en plus les
sites internet enfreignent la loi parce
que depuis 2020 il est interdit au site
internet de diffuser des contenus aux
mineurs alors eux ils avaient choisi
comme comme processus de sélection de
demander à l'utilisateur s'il y avait
plus de 18 ans en un clic on a jugé que
c'était absolument pas efficace donc je
crois savoir qu'en ce moment une
expérimentation est menée avec un site
internet pour justement mettre en place
un filtre par on appelle ça de double
anonymat justement pour pouvoir empêcher
l'accès à des contenus donc on espère en
tout cas je serai très attentive
évidemment à l'examen de ce texte dans
lequel je souhaite justement être
pleinement actif pour suivre les
évolutions mais je crois savoir
justement que nos recommandations ne se
rapportent seront prises en charge qui
viseront bien entendu à enfin pouvoir
appliquer la loi et protéger nos enfants
merci Steve bien sûr des violences
contre les élus tout à l'heure ce sera à
suivre dans le club à tout à l'heure on
va parler de votre partie les ténors des
républicains ont présenté leur mesure
pour lutter contre l'immigration pour
durcir la politique migratoire alors on
a bien vu cette volonté de s'afficher
uni il y avait Olivier marlex Bruno
retailleux Eric ciotic qui parlait d'une
seule voix est-ce que ces propositions
elles font vraiment l'unanimité au sein
de votre partie alors au sein de notre
partie politique évidemment elles font
l'unanimité et je crois que cette
volonté justement un peu d'agir tous
numéro de la droite donc je crois que
c'était un test qui un texte qui est
courageux assumé qui est pleinement dans
les valeurs de notre famille politique
et qui arrive à un moment où
ça devient une urgence aujourd'hui de
réguler l'immigration je crois que notre
pays en l'occurrence la France a le
droit de choisir son immigration
aujourd'hui les chiffres explosent on va
pas les rappeler ici mais c'est
indéniable il y a de plus en plus de
titres de séjour qui sont délivrés on a
dépassé les 30 000 en 2022 quand en 2012
ou Nicolas Sarkozy c'était beaucoup
moins de 100 000 donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une urgence à
réguler personne peut le nier personne
peut s'opposer à ça bien sûr il y aura
toutes les voix qui vont s'exprimer au
sein de notre famille politique nous
sommes en une famille politique de
débats d'échanges chacun fera entendre
sa voix mais je pense qu'on fera
consensus sur ce sujet au sein des
républicains et au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale parce que la majorité c'est
naturel c'est la droite et le centre on
a appris que les centristes allaient
également déposer leurs propres
proposition de loi est-ce que ce sujet
est en train de fracturer la majorité
sénatoriale non je crois que la majorité
Sénator elle porte son nom déjà de
travailler en partenariat après je
trouve ça totalement sain que chacun
appartient à une famille politique avec
des marqueurs qui lui sont propres donc
l'Union centriste en l'occurrence pour
le Sénat va proposer et bien son projet
sur l'immigration je suis sûr qu'on se
retrouve sur un certain nombre de points
que chacun ait ces marqueurs c'est le
propre de chaque partie politique mais
comme on a toujours travaillé en
adéquation j'ai aucun souci de dialogue
entre notre président de groupe Bruno
Retailleau et Hervé Marseille le
président de l'Union centrée vous pensez
qu'il pourra en Boutière ces textes et
comment est-ce que vous pensez alors au
Sénat déjà il faut voir si la majorité
sénatoriale va aller voter mais à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
pensez vraiment que les textes vont
aboutir alors qu'on sait qu'une partie
de la majorité présidentielle et sur une
ligne beaucoup plus à gauche je crois
que c'est toute la force de notre
famille politique c'est de convaincre
justement avec un texte qui est
réalisable qui est ambitieux mais qui
est réaliste et qui part des chiffres
incontestés et donc le travail du
Parlement c'est de débattre mais je
crois aujourd'hui que j'ai pleinement
confiance dans les députés les
républicains même s'ils sont mineurs
pour convaincre la majorité
présidentielle pour convaincre
l'ensemble des députés sur cette
nécessité en tout cas et que j'espère
qu'ils pourront avancer un certain
nombre de points essentiels que nous en
tout cas évidemment on a pu savoir que
ça fait 18 mois que le ministre de
l'Intérieur nous annonce un texte sur
l'immigration et que si nous avons
souhaité aujourd'hui prendre les devants
c'est parce que nous étions taux nous
sommes toujours en attente de ce texte
qui devrait être débattu à l'heure où on
se parle vous et moi donc et qui
n'arrive pas donc c'était notre
responsabilité aussi notre famille
politique de prendre les devants pour
justement proposer un texte parce que
nous sommes responsables et qu'il y a
urgence aujourd'hui à réguler
l'immigration de notre pays on je l'ai
dit il y avait une volonté aussi des
républicains de s'afficher unis sur ce
texte c'était pour faire oublier la
séquence catastrophique des retraites on
a toujours été uni sur le texte des
retraites également c'est pas parce
qu'ils n'ont pas fait une de JDD
ensemble qu'il n'était pas uni je crois
que
il y a eu c'est un sujet quand même les
retraites qui a toujours suscité des
polémiques ce n'est pas un sujet on l'a
vu là avec l'examen sur les retraites
notamment au Sénat c'est un sujet qui
peut diviser sur certains problématiques
on comprend aussi l'enjeu je crois que
sur le sujet de l'immigration et je
reviens un peu à ce qu'on s'est dit tout
à l'heure c'est un marqueur de droite
c'est un sujet qui fait partie plein de
notre famille politique donc on ne
pouvait pas se rassembler donc après le
texte des retraites où on était aussi
Unis malgré quelques voies dissonantes
au sein de notre famille il y en a chez
dans votre famille politique ils disent
qu'ils voteront la proposition liotte
d'abrogation de la réforme des retraites
c'est pas un problème ça pour vous il y
aura toujours des voix dissonantes et on
n'est pas là pour obliger l'ensemble de
nos collègues à s'allier à notre cause
mais en tout cas une majorité de une
grande majorité d'ailleurs de des
parlementaires les républicains et des
élus aussi en France sont rassemblés
derrière justement ce projet qui est
porté par Olivier Marleix au nouveau
taillot Éric Ciotti avec ses deux
propositions là merci beaucoup merci
première demi-heure dans 20 minutes dans
le club des territoires on reviendra sur
le climat de violence dans la société
dont on a parlé agression d'élus de
soignants de policiers comment
l'expliquer comment sortir ce sera le
débat du club et d'abord on va reparler
notamment du texte qui a été voté hier
dans vous étiez la rapporteur avec
Charlotte cobel qui nous rejoint